- I've never let go of my vision.
To commit to the commitment,
is very powerful.
I only try to do one thing at a time.
- Need motivation?
- What's your Top 10, with Believe Nation.
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
I believe in you,
and this channel is designed to be part
of your daily success routine.
So, let's get your motivation to a 10,
and get you believing in you.
Grab a snack, and chew
into today's lessons
from a woman who went from
being a anthropology student,
to dropping out of school
to become an actress,
to becoming an Academy
Award Winning actress,
and successful entrepreneur.
She's Gwyneth Paltrow,
and here is my take on her
top 10 rules to success.
(upbeat music)
Okay, let's kick it off
with rule number one,
take risks.
- You know for me, I took
a crazy risk, you know?
I really did have a
perfectly good day job.
- [Man] It was really going well?
- It was going great.
- Were you nervous?
Were you really scared to jump in,
or what were you feeling?
- I was scared,
but I had self belief.
And that's what I think ultimately...
Because people knock
you down all the time,
and they poke holes,
and they don't like this
about your business model,
and they don't believe in you.
You know, you just have
to keep getting back up,
and getting back up,
and getting back up.
And I think what got me through,
was this I've never let go of my vision.
It's like I just see a bulls eye,
and it might be really, really far away,
but I'm going straight for it,
and doing the best I can.
But, in the meantime,
I'm building a really
interesting business.
- Rule number two, value time.
- What's the best piece of advice
you've ever been given,
that you keep with you to this day?
- My dad gave me the best advice,
pertaining to every situation.
In my 20s, I was having trouble
with one of my girlfriends,
who I've known since grade school.
And he said, "You can't
make new old friends."
And it really stuck with me.
Now, that's actually a piece of advice
I think you can apply
it to other things too.
It's like, the value in time,
you know it's sort of like
what you were saying with cash.
The value that's created when two people
make a commitment,
whether it's a relationship,
or a friendship,
or a parent child relationship,
to commit to the commitment
is very powerful.
- It is very powerful.
- Rule number three, like yourself.
- What is the single most important thing
that changed that you're grateful,
that you made when it
comes to your own wellness?
- I think deciding that I liked myself,
and that I didn't really ultimately...
It didn't serve me what other
people's opinions were of me,
good or bad,
whatever that projection was
really wasn't serving me.
And I think around the
time that I turned 40,
I felt like I got a software upgrade.
And I was like, "Oh,
I kind of like myself,
"and I kind of don't give a."
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
I think it's a real blessing,
and I think everybody when they turn 40,
gets this software upgrade
and it's been an incredible blessing.
I think because with that
has come a lot of self-acceptance,
and forgiveness,
and being present and open,
and not fighting so hard against this idea
of what I thought I was supposed to be,
or where I was supposed to be,
or what kind of marriage
I was supposed to have,
or X,Y and Z.
I really accepted myself,
and that I think I feel so
much better having done that,
than I did from doing Yoga
and eating macrobiotic food.
- Rule number four, build
something you believe in.
- Has anything surprised you
about being an entrepreneur?
Before you came in,
and you decided to fully
throw yourself all in?
Anything surprised you
about this experience?
- I mean, so many things surprise me.
I had no idea what I was getting into,
I had no idea how much I didn't know,
and how much there was to learn.
I had no idea how much I was in a career
where everyone kissed my ass,
and now people are like well you.
What's the bottom line?
(laughing)
Like, oh.
Now I'm like on jet blue.
I'm like, "What the did I do here?"
(laughing)
But honestly, I've never felt
so professionally fulfilled
in my life,
and it's such a grind,
and it's such hard work,
but it's so amazing to
be building something
that you believe in,
and making product that you love,
and putting it into the world,
and getting feedback
positive and negative,
and sorting through it.
I much prefer it,
even though no one kisses my ass anymore.
- Rule number five, learn
how to deal with criticism.
- So, this is what Martha Stewart
said about Gwyneth a couple of weeks ago.
This was well before
the lease announcement.
"She just needs to be quiet,
"she's a movie star.
"If she were confident in her acting,
"she wouldn't be trying
to be Martha Stewart."
(laughing)
- First of all,
no one has ever said
anything bad about me before,
so I'm shocked and devastated.
I'll try to recover.
You know, if I'm really honest,
I am so psyched that she
sees us as competition.
Like, I'm so psyched.
I think that when anybody
criticizes anyone,
it really is just revealing
more about where they are
in time and space,
as opposed to where you
are in time and space.
And I think generally we
tend to you know lash out,
if we're in a...
You know what I mean?
It's usually a reflection
of something else,
and so I try not to...
In this point in my life,
I don't take it personally.
I see it as a projection,
and you know if there's
ever anything that sticks,
then I know oh maybe I'm holding
this judgment against myself,
and I need to look at that.
But, it's very interesting.
And you know, sometimes I learn
good things from criticism.
- Rule number six, start small.
- I want to know about the first time
you set your finger tips to keyboard,
and decided to start a weekly newsletter.
- It really kind of came about
in a very small way.
Me in my kitchen with my girlfriends,
talking about ideas.
And then, what started to happen,
was essentially there was a
trust that started to get built
between myself and my readers,
and there was a lot of traction
that started to happen.
If I recommended something that I found,
or that I loved,
then I was starting to
have this amazing feedback
from these businesses saying this has
a real measurable, big impact.
And I was like, "Oh wow,
that's interesting."
And so, it was kind of all piece by piece.
It was a very slow, very
organic process over years.
You know I've been doing
it for a really long time.
Until I sort of started to think,
"Well, I wonder how I would do this,
"if I wanted to turn it into a business?
"If I wanted to monetize it?
"Do I want to do that?
"Would I ever have advertising,
"would I ever sell anything?
"What would I sell?"
And the process just was a slow evolution.
- Rule number seven, learn
through trial and error.
- You know, what was the transition
going from a huge Hollywood
actress, huge star,
to entrepreneur?
How did you learn?
Did you kind of seek mentors,
do you just kind of learn
through trial and error?
- A lot of trial and error,
a lot of epic mistakes.
- What were some epic mistakes you made?
- You know, just...
There's 1,000.
I mean like for example,
not understanding...
Not understanding the importance
of doing your own due diligence.
Whether it's on hiring someone,
I'd be like,
"Oh, they seem great, fine."
You know, you might want to check,
or switching email service providers.
What might this entail?
I had a huge problem
recently when I did that,
because I just didn't do the research
and I didn't know.
Now I know.
- Rule number eight,
do one thing at a time.
- The thing that I've learned
that's helped me the most,
is that I only try to
do one thing at a time.
So, if I'm picking up my kids from school,
I'm not trying to also
make decisions about work.
Because, I find that I do both badly,
so I really try to carve out my time well.
- Rule number nine,
listen kingly and openly.
- [Woman] So, you talked about the fact
that you've had some separation
between being an actress,
and being an entrepreneur.
But, there must be some skills
that you're able to take
from being an actress,
to becoming an entrepreneur.
And I was wondering what those were?
- Oh, that's a really good question,
nobody's ever asked me that before.
I think they're more interpersonal skills.
Like when you're acting with somebody,
like listening, respect,
kind of being a container.
I think establishing that kind of rapport,
and respect for people,
and listening kindly and openly.
Those sort of skills that
help you be a good actress,
I think help you in business.
Because, in my experience
they create more points of connection,
and when you work with people,
and you have the capacity to listen,
and you have the respect back and forth,
the best of that person starts to emerge.
It's been amazing.
You know, I have my girls
that I love so much.
And to see them grow and
create roles for themselves,
and then fill the roles in the business,
it's amazing.
And I do think that comes
from a very specific type
of listening that you learn from acting.
- And rule number 10, the last one
before a very special bonus clip,
is have fun.
- Never ever have I lied to get a job.
- Oh, come on.
- How would you lie?
(laughing)
- Never ever have I gotten
out of a speeding ticket
by being a celebrity.
(audience laughing)
Never ever have I forgotten
the name of a date.
Like while you're with them?
I don't understand that.
While you're with them?
- While you're with them?
- That would be really horrific.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- No, I've never.
- Never ever have I seen
one of my Mortdecai's
co-stars naked?
(audience cheering)
Never ever have I lied on a talk show.
(audience laughing)
- I don't believe you.
It's just unbelievable.
- Never ever have I sexted.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah no, I haven't done that.
- Wow.
- Never ever have I said a baby was cute
when it was obviously ugly.
(audience laughing)
- All right, I've got a very special
bonus clip from Gwyneth,
on how to try things,
and the importance of it that I think
you're going to really enjoy.
But before that,
it's time for the three
point landing questions.
Time to move from just
watching under the video,
to actually taking action
in your life and business.
So, here we go.
Question number one,
how can you just start small today
on your big dreams?
Number two, what is a risk you
are going to take this week?
And number three,
what habits will you build in
to like yourself regularly?
- And I think, you know my whole
sort of road towards wellness,
started my father was
diagnosed with cancer
when I was about 26.
And that's when I started reading
about environmental toxins,
and the connection
between food and cancer,
and stress and cancer.
And so, I really started
to become obsessive
about in a vain effort to heal him,
kind of by proxy because he
really wasn't that interested.
Health food.
I remember I was trying to
make him go gluten free,
and dairy free,
and sugar free,
and I spent all day making these muffins,
because you know all he
wanted was to feel normal
after his cancer.
I made these muffins with
I don't know coconut sugar,
and whatever kind of flour.
And he bit into one,
and I was like, "What do you think?"
And he said, "It's like biting
into the New York Times."
(laughing)
So, he was among the first
who was sort of critical
of my furies into wellness.
You know, I think that I remember
once I had acupuncture and cupping,
which is an ancient Chinese technique,
and there was this big
uproar in the press,
and I was a witch,
and what was I doing.
When I starting doing yoga 20 years ago,
the press had a field day with that.
And I've just sort of
by pattern recognition
realized that I'm somebody
who likes to try things,
and then people think I'm insane.
Now there's a yoga place on every corner,
no one eats gluten anymore.
- If I've talked to one
person who's been successful,
they all say at some point
people ridiculed them,
criticized them,
thought they were nuts,
and I think that it's really important
that if you believe in your idea,
if you have an ability to shut that out,
you can persevere .
- Raise your standard.
- Apple at the core,
its core value is that we
believe that people with passion
can change the world for the better.
- Not one drop of my self worth
depends on your acceptance of me.
(dramatic music)
- If you guys liked this video,
check out the top 10
we did on Jessica Alba.
It's right next to me,
I think you're going to enjoy it.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you there.
- I spend a lot of time
in my head fantasizing
about being a superhero,
and about being somebody else,
and what would it be like to live?
(dramatic sound)